So this is all right you. Should cover church. K.o.v. Icy icy. Sky came up here when i was about mines martin.
I've been out of high school for two years. I'm writing. Planning on going back to university next year.
I came to new when i was about nine. So that means how long is that. Nineteen twenty now.
So that's more than ten years. I've been up in this area. I spent. Probably most of my school years.
Living in the area if not travelling to lose more to go to high school.
I spent the last three days of promise school here.
And i've sort of seen i've had things to do with both sides of the name been in town.
More there's there's always been a sort of division or. A pretty recognizable rift between. Between the original.
Although the old timers you know the rednecks the settlers. Dairy farmers. What have you.
And the alternative community which came in after seventy three
and a even though they're sort of pretty much reconciled now.
I've noticed that that division has always been there and i think it always will be there.
You know and i've seen it not only in nimbin. But in any way. You know where that where that's have alternative.
Sort of. Our pricing is happened. It's sort of a it's a big influential thing on the society but it's not actually.
Assimilated into it all that much. You know there's a bit of. Bit of resentment and stuff left behind. Right ok.
Probably a really vivid memory that i always have seen coming into.
Name them when i was nine years old for the first time with my auntie and. Mother and cousins and people.
And it was hot summer day really hot and dragonflies a buzzing around.
And the one thing i could sense was the smells you know. You know what.
Nimbin has this distinctive smell which is really different. It was a mixture of.
Poor poor vision and grass and sort of. You know. Animals and sweat and and. You know. Feted human smells you know and.
We just i've been up this big pool poor on this. And this watermelon on this type will. And i to.
And it's just the sort of. It's my first memory of newman. Was from that time and.
Other than that i've just got a sort of continuing. Memory from when i was young and. Of sun was up in x.
Land which is sort of. Just blood and you've been wrong. You know. The images of some the strange and the cash shit.
And the mud. And the insects and incense and things like that. And sort of.
I think that belongs to childhood not i really can't recapture that anymore.
Too much has happened since to be able to sort of retrieve that top of idyllic. Ideal feeling that. It was there. Well.
I never consciously realised that my parents were different from anyone else's parents. And it was only.
I only learnt it externally from other people and from other people sort of. Disparagement and.
Which meant that when i got a primary school for example me for. I was only about nine. You know.
I'm wearing a full moon for will jump out. Nothing underneath.
You know big pair of baggy cotton pants and now into pens now underway no shoes. Long hair. Feathers and kids saying.
You know. You know.
Really being ostracized in school which was really bad and kids saying well you know do you have what she had.
Do you brush your teeth you know. If you got a disease you know what languages do you speak type thing.
And it was pretty bad for war. But i learned how to. I think actually what happened to our generation my generation.
Is that after. After going through that original. Rejection time.
By by out the peers we actually became much more conservative than our parents were.
Which means that now we're sort of integrating back into sort of mainstream. A striving middle class.
Technological society. There's a bit of it. There's a bit of a backlash actually. Which is pretty pretty big.
You know i didn't go to the camo school. But my mom taught there for watermark a lot of friends from there.
I started off in the central school which was always a stronghold of. You know. Dairy found the sons and daughters.
Are not once or twice playground fights. Prejudice. Just general small minded. You know. Typically strain.
Narrow minded thing but the thing about it was it was never too serious.
You know nothing and nothing too bad at the happened.
It was just the ways that i was with the hippies and those with the good guys you know the cricket players and stuff.
You're either cricket player or your hippie. And hippies didn't play balls or. Cricket or you know something.
They went around sort of raiding herman hesse or. Burning incense or. You know talking about. Shit. Christian thing.
But you know. But that sort of young kid sort of picking up symbols and images of themselves last bus.
Well we were just always into we were into each other. Which is something i think a lot of other kids. When.
We're into just discovering each other in a sort of pretty personal way. I just remember. You know sort of.
Looking from school and going down to the river and swimming and stuff like that you know naked and spying secrets
and later on smoking marijuana and girls and parties and sort of. It was.
It was a way of life which we picked up from our parents because i suppose we.
You know we imitate our parents more than anyone else. And. And that was just not.
You know there was any group of about six of us or something that did that.
And everyone else was pretty much into something bad beatles or something. Something else. Yeah do. I have.
I haven't like. I actually when i first come up to name and. I've lived in paradise valley for about.
About three months before my mum came up from sydney she was the working at a school down there.
And i was living with this group of adults. Of whom my stepfather was one and. I really remember their.
I pin this and their sort of generosity and their sort of feels in this you know that will sit around and just.
I suppose it was a typical middle class top of. Adult gathering. Insofar as that they're all educated they've been any.
Psychologists lectures teachers doctors. And they.
But i i had a sense of togetherness which i really hadn't seen before in the city. You know. I've been brought up.
Going to very schools in the city you know. My parents were sort of.
Divorced when i was quite young and a lot type thing i was always used to. Displacement or disembodiment.
Or something which was which was. I you know. Broken a path. And like me when i.
First came to him in the first thing i saw amongst the adults was this.
Cohesion and just a seriousness of purpose as well. An integrity that what they were doing.
And yet i had a lot of fun too. You know.
I mean it wasn't serious as nothing too serious about there was no big big you know.
Bloody ross the system all big kamin see it over
and i was just until people deciding to have a lot of fun in their lives you know.
After going through the rat rights fees and and.
I suppose that me my friends will pick up on that i mean we still laugh. Well. We've sort of.
We've all moved on our own individual lives really like.
A lot of my very close friends from paving from the early days. Have gone to uni.
Like one of them has just graduated with honors in your apology to a new.
He's off in england at the moment looking at uni's over there. Which is pretty impressive. You know.
My sister is down in sydney. Finishing off an economics degree now and things and others of us are still up here.
Like myself. Like luke who plays music or play music we. We do things are right. As well.
And that's alright we sort of. I think really that.
Nimbin didn't have such an impact on us that we were going to fall into one of it's types of categories whether it was
get too far into drugs that we became junkies will become full on hippies or whatever we're going to do we.
We followed our own paths. You know which were all different. Some of us have been back a few years. Differently.
Absolutely. Well. The people who who are. I knew. As a kid who i now know to be. You know. Full on addicts.
Quite seriously. Ruined by drugs by hard drugs were always a bit. A bit self destructive anyway and.
Whether they're in yemen or wherever they were there in the streets or chippendale sorry hills or brunswick street
or wherever they were. Those who talk to people who are going to get into that anyway.
So i don't think there's always an argument that nimbin produces. The circumstances for people to become junkies but.
I think that that. That. That's i don't post and choice. So i mean i i remember a girl who who was really amazing.
And she. She taught me how to ride a horse. I knew a few years like the seventies or something.
And last year i learned that she thought of a no team has been. And that. That really threw me a lot and.
She didn't have any friends. She just couldn't handle it. So she died.
And you know there's quite a few stories like that around. But then again there are people who are sort of.
Not seen or heard of for quite a few years now and they've disappeared into the woodwork. And there's no there's no.
Thing about nimbin this is no real support system for people who have gone into that type of thing.
I don't know whether that should be a social concern or a hospital concern or sort of parents' concern
but for all the kids who are out there on their own and homeless. There's no real support system for them.
And that's pretty sad. You know. It's pretty bad. Marijuana fitted into. Into the usual young. Simian rebellious semi.
Celebration resort of thing about. You know just being out there and going.
Getting away from your parents without hippies or bureaucrats or businessmen
or whatever they were getting away from them getting away from school.
Getting away from your own ambitions whatever it is and having a good time with your friends.
And it was never a serious thing for me. I mean i haven't smoked for a long time.
And lot of my friends have any that they selected to go. The line. When they finish high school and. It does change.
It does sort of affect affect your development. In certain ways it opens you up to different.
Different thoughts and different ways of looking at things but then again it's. It's like any drug it's recreational.
It's. If you have too much of it it's not good for you. You know. So marijuana use.
The thing about marijuana there was lots of people going to dealing. Which is pretty. I was. I was sort of.
Was critical of that. Because i thought it was a bit. You know better things to do than get into dealing marijuana.
And they're still doing it. And i think that's a destructive force in my own peace you know my own sort of generation.
But you know. Again that's the choice. And sort of. I can't. I find it hard to be able to justify a lot of people's.
Reasons for doing things.
I couldn't put it down to it being their choice so marijuana is something that all of us experience that people do
experience everywhere. Wherever they are. And it's a great it's a great thing it's like.
It's like anything it's like the joys of life you know. And it's just it's just a matter of abuse and acceptance.
I suppose. Yes absolutely absolutely. When i remember that when i was eighteen. I was fully into drama. Right.
Why but drama was it. And i remember just reading shakespeare and reading all of the cars.
And what we decide to do is to start up a new drama troupe. You know just of young kids promise school educates and.
I remember we put on about two productions a very sings light off and you learn. People like that and.
Our member writing two plays. Really funny little. Sort of plays. About just about us i suppose.
And we actually put the morning town. You know. Audiences came in those drinks and wine and cheese and.
Music and it was really good. And that happened.
You know probably when i was eleven and twelve which is young time for that to happen.
There was also a classical music side which i played out every week. Which was really good for furthering you know.
Mine and everyone else's musical. Sort of skill or practice or whatever you know. We used to sort of. And have weekly.
Gatherings at the town hall. And about eight o'clock on sunday nights. And just play music. House.
People sit around in questions and i'd get up and play some clarinet.
Sinatra and my sis to play the chill live in mother play the piano and. It was really good. It was very informal.
I mean i'm sure squeaking the whole time. You know. That was acceptable.
Yeah so definitely there was a lot of a lot of help in us.
As far as getting us into our own thing was concerned you know whether it was musical.
Skateboarding or whatever the hell it was you know it was all. Wise.
All right to be doing those things you know you didn't have to be going off
and achieving what school you have to be you know.
Fulfilling the expectations of your grandparents or or your parents or teachers or whatever it was.
It was always very much an individual orientated thing. I don't know where that was more so than anywhere else.
But it seemed that way. That's really true not only is it a challenge. It's a year. It's. Being in nimbin.
And feeling the need to break out of nimbin. And go to the city. And achieve something else is not only a challenge.
It. It's also a very difficult thing to do emotionally. Because once you've been up here.
If you've been up here for as long as i have which is more than ten years.
You become really attached to what is basically a paradise. And you begin to wonder will.
Is there really need to go to the city is there really need to get a degree is there a need to achieve something
and become a sort of working. Functioning member of a sort of open society.
And you really think now there isn't a need for that. But yes it's a challenge.
And it's a nice challenge but i think even supplies will come back to you know.
Over time will be coming back i've always come back here. Ferals. I don't remember there always being ferals actually.
I think. Feral seems to be one of the lightest phases of existential billion with the with. Comes from. It's from punk.
From skinhead from from whatever. I don't really. I just think that farrel's.
It's important for whoever decides to become that that. Out. Lee.
Contemptuous of everything learns how to integrate at some point.
And the fact is that all of the ferals do people for government.
Which isn't isn't a bad thing or anything but you know. That's how we work our society but.
It'd be nice if one day they. They learned how to my own nature or something and they set up workshops and they sold.
Surely they sold handcrafts all. So close to something like that because at the moment they're really quite there.
Even there be exported to there. Why not. I don't i've never really had any interaction with ferals apart from.
Mating the minute. In a crate all getting stoned with them was something.
I think they're just fun loving people who just want to have a good time. But it's a juvenile type of thing.
It's an important thing but it's juvenile and i think it's something that had to grow out of eventually. Well.
The boys seemed to sort of revolve around. Around what's happening drug wise. Ah.
That sounds like a general statement but at first it was always just the pace loving he.
You know stereotypical sixty's american images of he who who really just wanted to live peacefully on a calming smoke.
Your joint. Right smack a mean cocaine mean. All this stuff you know. Designer drugs are in there now.
And people changing. You know.
You get sort of yuppie middle class suburbanites from brisbane will see me coming up
and down to to buy their trucks here setting up new businesses and. And what have you so newman's lost its original.
Idealistic sort of cohesion it. And it's become a bit disparate. And a bit sort of a bit scattered in that way.
You know. It's the drug culture has. Has given such a commercial center.
As far as business is concerned that there's no real social conscience anymore.
And that's sad because you can see it in the street and you can see it in the people but at the same time.
It's becoming much more neary. And it's.
It's turning into a pretty peaceful middle class hamlet at the same time where. Whereby you've got.
Families who aren't into drugs at. Or aren't into anything to alternative coming up.
Having kids living in actually living really pays full and. You know make a logical sound and happy lives.
Out in the hills you know. I suppose they aren't farming fully conscious. But it's not.
It's not a self-conscious thing like it was in the early guys.
And that's really good
and i think the more of that that happens everywhere on the straight the better because it needn't be.
The sudden or revolutionary or or. Aggressive towards the old settlers there. Like it was in seventy three.
But it can be integrated into the mainstream society.
You know which simply just means learning how to live with with an awareness about what you're doing with your rubbish.
You know where you put in a plastic. Where you put in your bottles. Where you're putting the sheet.
You know working out how you can use you use your own land. For the most you know. Most convenient purposes and.
Efficient purposes without destroying what you've got which is what perma culture is all about.
And that started off here.
And learning about the social the social sort of relevance of that as far as your kids are concerned and.
What school to send them to all things like that. You know. And that's that's where nimbin has its strengths now.
It doesn't have it in the old. Nostalgic. Yearnings of the dugout paypal it's got it in the.
Hard working conscious and yet mainstream. Middle class trend it's been happening in the last five years.
And other than that other than the sort of. Other than the yuppie drug scene in the.
And the middle class families saying child put it.
I can't really think of there being any other one just rent there's always the rebellious.
Clique from sydney from newtown from glee. Who decide to come up and check nimbin out.
But it's usually be too slow and they end up going back. Back home to sydney.
Or the others there's a bit of an aboriginal community developing as well which is good because i always.
I always noticed. Conspicuously that there weren't many aboriginals in yemen. And there they were.
And they're actually getting land for example there's a. There's quite a large community at the base of nimbin rocks.
Who have reclaimed their land and it's their land. And they all lived there.
And it's really good and they're quite happy in.
And everyone interacts with them and i enjoy it with us and it's really good. So it's you know.
It's pretty much all be one family. As far as they're concerned now which is good.
Apart from that i can only think of any other. So cultural trend that's taking place in human. Well it's.
There are a few. There are a few of us who've decided to do that but it's much less. Self consciously alternative.
Than what our parents who are the basically people who who want to settle down. Have families if they can leave.
You know leaving their out house if i can afford that. But they're also basically people who are still trying for some.
Some sort of occupation you haven't got any any real. Livelihood. Yet.
And so they're not really getting into perm culture and not really getting into. Into. Hippiedom.
As such what they getting into is just staying up here rather than going to city.
So i don't know whether that's a regressive step what it is i think it's.
It really matters to make a judgment on that level but. But they're. They're much more ordinary that things you know.
And most of the moment all you know all be getting that all in a couple of months or something.
After a while to thirteen weeks but yeah it sort of there's a lot of. There's a lot of.
Pull towards just staying sort of going and.
I think it'll change i think over the next few decades name them will become so much more of an ordinary place.
You know. A kind. It will become pretty much a country town with. With different tendency. He's now.
And that's about it. Well. I think it's a very simple thing which is that when you've been exposed to.
Such a wide variety of different life. Lifestyle options.
You know it comes as no surprise that what you would naturally get. Is is a wide and.
Open and accepting
and tolerating view of society as a whole which i suppose on a personal level means that that having been brought up in
sydney as a young kid. And sort of going to private schools. Until i was seven or six or whatever.
You know it's a close type of life it's a close lifestyle it's very much a middle class protected.
Financially secure conservative type of wives. Of living. Coming up here just opened me up to a completely different.
Freedom.
Which which and fortunately lot of people in this country haven't got the opportunity to to experience you know.
And so it's a living. Growing up up here has opened me to a whole different range of spiritual practices.
And i mean you know.
The simple fact that there is there's a krishna krishna sort of settlement in the will and bar that there's so much.
There's so much and discipline which is seriously followed up here.
Is is impressive you know to a young person to a young person's impressionable mind.
And that's something which i just know. Wouldn't have been an issue. In sydney.
And i can see it now because i had friends in sydney when i was a kid and. And i still know them. And we've grown up.
Parallel although they've grown up down there i've grown up here and they. And this sort of.
Into what they're doing
but they're very commercially oriented they're very consumer oriented they're much more into finding out.
What money they can get hold of whatever they can they're into urban types of. Types of hobby. While i was doing.
Drama or something up here that we're doing sky boarding in the streets of manly whatever you know.
While i was smoking marijuana that were probably taking ecstasy or designer drugs you know and stuff.
It's just a different type of slant on things. One is a bit more competitive in rat race than the other.
And each have this sort of negative tendencies in their positive tendencies. But i think that the mere fact that.
Being up here for so long and experiencing the different types of people i have up here.
If you know of his many years i have mains that may and. Young people like myself. Have got quite a wide and accepting.
A more educated you're more informed about about a strange society. And it's sort of subcultures as a whole you know.
It's a. It's a general sort of statement i think.
I think the wider view you have the more the more informed you are about your society. Well.
Well it is totally confusing the thing about the spiritual. Sort of a thought that is playing around in these hills.
Is that people become very self-indulgent and they become quite self preoccupied.
Which is which i suppose it's all right for an individual in some part of his life
but in the end you've got to get down to the real the real hard work. Digging the shit. And.
And so you know what you probably see up here is a lot of.
Of quite precious people going around spouting forth their little philosophies. But see that's.
You know that's what it's all about you've got to have somewhere in the country that does that not everyone can be out.
Being business executives or something.
You know knowing their fast buck you know someone's going to be delivering their philosophies however how.
Like they may be. So that's what it's like up here you know and it's good because in the end it is confusing.
You know it is confusing there's a lot of stuff that's going around and three. You know.
Especially before you've developed your own firm beliefs about the world.
It's hard to know which are really where it's i don't know. You know. A lot of them they just real crap.
And a lot of them are quite quite inspiring. So i mean there's a lot of. You've got you've got a cult has.
Transcendental yogis set on these side issues all those people out there doing what i do. And i suppose.
You witness it. And you observe and you appreciate it and you take a choice. Here. Do i have one.
Look like this many stupid u.p.i. Do is i really can't choose or now. I really can't think of one.
I can't think of one. A funny name in story. I can't. It's hard to think. Think of an author like him. Will.
From a from me.
The real the real beauty in the real importance about living up here is being the natural the natural abundance of the
life which has meant that over the years of our. Really learned how to how to live out there and.
You know which which included. Trips walking. Dyce cross not cat range. Ridge.
From from the him being here to the to the bison. The mound in the hills. You know which meant. Sort of.
Getting on my horse with some friends in for three days camping in writing from here through the forest up to the bison
the pinnacle over there which you can see. You know which. Which meant.
Just being so inspired by the landscape that i'd go out and buy a canvas and paints to try and paint what i could say.
Pretty poorly probably. But it's. You know it's just such an inspiring thing to be in you know having.
Having the opportunity to go down to hangar falls. Every week and swim down there in this amazing.
Natural water for well. And all of that. It's just it's amazing thing to be able to do. As a kid.
When you're growing up and i really i do pity a lot of.
A lot of people who who just haven't known that part that part about a stride
or that part about being out in the country. And sort of hippiedom. And drug culture and all of that is around.
But for me it always lies at.